Oh Oh God
very dangerous
she just take my joy children Percy
Percy
what have you been up to
no one's seen you for hours Oh lows to
the grindstone you know then why haven't
I heard a single whoosh through the door
since 10 o'clock did you forget we're
having deer Drew's birthday party we've
got a pinata right brilliant of course
have you forgotten your joy course not
snug as a bug on a drug well come on
then finish up I just have a few more
pages I know you're very busy then don't
take too long to finish well I expect
you in the conference room presently
don't dawdle you don't want to miss the
pinata Oh wasn't prudence supposed to be
coming back today
I made her a welcome back card
do you think the canister wonders what
life's like outside the tube
of course I'd have to break the cheat to
get out I won't break it for everybody
you know coming back all you prove why
did you go
we seem to be a bit behind in our work
get that good doctor right now
there you are
you nearly missed the pinata it's the
most adorable Spanish custom Uncle Jack
did a whole show about it
now smash it until all the candy comes
out come on hit it he did it he did give
it a whack et hit it
you are off your joy take one of mine oh
my god
he's a down cool security we got a
downer
ah
love-love
you